um let's take a listen this is it she's
interesting because she says that she
she stays home
her husband works she takes a lot of
heat from other women for that but just
take a listen to what she has to say
about why every woman needs a man in her
life
honestly the reason why women say they
don't need a man is so that they can
look cool to their girlfriends like you
want to look impressive you want to look
like you can work in the world because
women judge other women the most like i
don't even think it's the patriarchy
holding us down i'm pretty sure it's the
matriarchy like all of the the disdain
that is i get looked down upon for
staying home and depending on my husband
all the time all the people call me lazy
people call me a gold digger women
shouldn't put each other down in that
way like you're probably just mad that
you have to work like i would hate me
too if i was in that situation it's to
look like you're valuable to your
girlfriend the thing about it is that
girlfriends aren't real though like
we're all getting we're all waiting to
get picked up by some guys so if your
girlfriends figure out the game before
you do you're gonna be by yourself
hanging out at the bar 35 like that is a
foolish plan but it's like every time i
watch one of these videos it's like i
start out in agreement and then it keeps
going and i'm like oh no and then i'm
like yeah they're like no
and it's like i just i don't know what
it is about it
but um okay so if you think she says
here that are true number one women do
judge the hell out of other women
i've worked in
sorry you know i worked on the view
mm-hmm
a lot of estrogen going on there i also
worked on a show at fox that was all
women um women are tough
on other women in fact some of the
most um how do what's the word that i
use here some of the most venomous
bosses i've had have been female there's
a lot of competition in the air there's
a lot of judgment there's a lot of focus
on people always think it's the guys
that focus on the physical appearance of
women
no one will criticize a woman
like a woman i mean she will get down to
the bobby pin in the back of your hair
that is not in right guys won't even
notice that guys don't notice 90 of
what's wrong i'll look it i'll leave the
house and i'll look at my husband i'll
be like oh babe you see how that little
he's like what are you what
what what are you talking about
girl will spot a zit on your face a mile
away and be like girlfriend didn't get
that cream from cbs
you know it natalia you know it it's
true i don't know girls know how to
criticize
other girls very well because they deal
with it they get ready every day they
know the struggle your eyebrows aren't
even ouch that yeah hurt my feelings and
they're mean
their girls can be very mean yes so i'm
not saying guys can't be mean of course
you know there's some guys girls have a
there's a telling you man the mean girls
you know that movie mean girls the mean
girls and the adult mean girls
next level stuff so they can be very
mean
very very mean to other women so she's
right about that i don't think that
women say they don't need a man because
um they're trying to like impress their
girlfriends so i think that line comes
out of you coming out of a bad situation
like when you say i don't need a man
oftentimes it's because you just had one
you got burned you're in a bad situation
and now you're in that like
i'm going to go out i'm going to get my
hair cut colored i'm going to put on an
outfit i'm going to go to the club i'm
going to feel like a rock star screw him
i don't need him blah blah blah i don't
need him in i think that's often times
where that comes out of i don't know any
women that sit around and say i don't
need a man because like they want their
girlfriends to pack them on the back i
think it's more like i don't need a man
because you've just been through it and
now you want to be like you know you're
going through the emotions the feels as
we call them you break up with somebody
it's never easy for a woman you always
got the nostalgia
you've got the like i hate him but i
still love him you've got the do i get
back with him all of a sudden everything
he ever did that was bad doesn't seem as
bad and all the stuff he ever did that
was good seems like he was like the guy
from the notebook
the romantic music plays way too often
in the background we're like staring out
the car window like tossing our hair i
mean you know we do it let's own it we
do it
um very complex creatures as i say
but um
yeah i think it's i think it's like you
come out of that and you want to like
you're like no i need to hate him right
now i need to hate him that's where i
need to be so i don't need a man it's a
lot of that i think if we're being
honest got to be honest
um the other thing that bothered me that
she says see she's got me right and i'm
like yeah yeah oh yeah i'm rooting for
and then she said like girlfriends
aren't real
i don't think that's true
um
i think there's circumstances where like
girls have a pack of girlfriends that
are like their
people their sisterhood that exists i
have my two best friends i have one girl
and i have one guy the girl like i've
known her since the sixth grade
she's like my sister like i don't have a
actual sister so she's my sister and um
there's nothing i don't tell her like i
tell her too much sometimes like jed man
i tell her everything she's been
she's seen it all let's just say that um
heard it all and i love that so the idea
that like girlfriends aren't real we're
all waiting to be picked up by some guy
i wouldn't say we were getting waiting i
wouldn't say we're waiting to be picked
up but essentially like we're working on
ourselves
so that we're able to have somebody
valuable enough in our eyes to not pick
us up but choose us yeah of other versus
other women out there i think that would
have been a better way to say what the
way this spread to me is a bunch of
girls are supposedly friends hanging out
at the club but they're not really real
friends they're all waiting to see like
who the guy's gonna pick and that's the
sole motivation i don't well you know
also when you go out to the club or go
out essentially like when men look at
girls they look at their group of girls
because they're like okay well pretty
girls hang around pretty girls you don't
see like pretty girls around like you
know so essentially like when men
when like when you are going out like
with a whole bunch of girls you are like
i can see why they would be like yeah
we're friends but not really because
we're all looking for the top tier guy
in the room so like i'm very i have two
friends too i only got two friends i
don't have no pack of friends i'm like
too many pack of friends get you in
trouble so
that's true it's very very circle small
good advice yes good advice keep the
circles yeah i guess um i guess that
could apply if it's like more
acquaintancy like people you hang out
with as opposed to like a real friend
exactly so maybe a little caveat there
would have helped but i i actually don't
think i mean listen i do think a lot of
girls are
looking for this is another thing with
the language that bugs me i think there
are a lot of women
you you want to find your partner right
most people want to find their partner
if you're being honest so i think you
are out and you're like you got your eye
open and you're hoping that you're going
to make a good match and you're looking
to see oftentimes you want the guy to
come up to you right so you want that
guy that right guy to kind of like you
scan the room you're looking around and
you want them to come over to you
uh because you you're looking for
something you know you want to make
something happen that's a different way
than saying we're all waiting to be
picked up by some guy
do you see what i'm just saying with the
language even because she makes great
points here this girl is going to turn
off a lot of women with this language
because now they're going to get
defensive
right they're going to get defensive
there are women out there that are
programmed to get defensive right they
just are they've got the feminist
talking points in their head like
rattling them all day long maybe they
would talk down to at one point whatever
the situation in their past was they are
like vulnerable to that defense like hit
a button and like they're gonna come
back and be like don't tell me i'm just
here waiting to find some man don't
don't make it like it's all about the
man's decision what if i want to go to
him those same women of course if you
say well do you go to him they'll say
well no i'm not gonna go to him i gotta
wait for him to come what kind of man's
gonna make me go to him it's craziness
it's all crazy bottom line just you know
think about how you say stuff if you're
concerned about bringing more people
into the loop if you're not more power
to her if you like the short clip you
can catch another one here or you can
catch the full episode right here
[Music]